we got this uh this story London and UK
Street news Pro Palestinian activists
throw live mice into McDonald's I kid
you not here's the video
clip all right we'll turn that down and
you've got the free Palestine they've
got the okay like seriously don't do
anything like this because dude what
like this so mean to the mice let alone
like the illegal the ille illegality of
doing this look at this this is pro
Palestinian activist walked into a
McDonald's this is in the UK they say
rats in McDonald's but these are clearly
mice God that's so messed up dude hell
no those poor mice like those mice are
probably going to get killed now because
of it for no reason they should be fed
to a snake or something and they want
you to do they going to do it in
Starbucks too what is the point what is
the point of ruining the community that
you live in they say hold on look at
this they they say Starbucks they say uh
target target targeted boycott the big
three start by boycotting these brands
that are directly involved in supporting
the Israeli aarthy Starbucks McDonald's
and Disney
Channel well okay how does that help
their cause I mean who's going to say oh
yeah they threw rats we got to be on
palestine's side
now and it's disruptive to business I
mean that's the point right you release
mice into a restaurant they have to shut
down for a couple hours McDonald maybe
not I don't McDonald the thread that
runs through a lot of the the protests
and stuff like that is just anti-western
anti- capitalism so the whole
Palestinian thing like the Palestinians
are fighting the Israelis the Israelis
are are generally looked at as a western
democracy this is an attack on
capitalism they think or they would
probably consider an attack on
capitalism an ATT an attack on Western
consumerism an attack on actual Western
uh you know things that in the west you
know so the the the fact that the left
is kind of a monolith now I think that
that's part of why it's playing out like
this and nothing will happen to them in
London and they know that London is a
disgrace the entire UK is a disgrace
what they let people get away with
that's why it's such a disaster over
there but you mess all of the amount of
raping the attacks the dis they're
literally arresting people for qu for
silently praying outside of an abortion
clinic several times there's a lot those
videos multiple people get arrested for
literally standing there and not soci
media post too I mean there are many
people I knew a woman over there went to
jail just because she used to go and
protest in hide Park she used to not
protest but you know speaker Corner
which was supposed to be all about Free
Speech they arrested this woman I know
two times because they didn't like her
speech well speaker Corner that's the
point of it the whole of Europe has
become woke and it's why they being
taken over that's why the whole place is
being destroyed you and they want us to
pay for their defense yeah sure we
shouldn't be giving them a thing we
should be out of NATO we should let them
just do whatever they want out of NATO
out of NATO get out get out let them
fend for themselves you want to be woke
you want to be all into that crap get
out this is going to be really
interesting though as uh uh that's
basically what's happening is the
American people are basically fed up
with the failures of Europe and US
footing the bill and we've been footing
the bill since basically World War I
yeah and why they're they're letting
themselves become invaded they are
allowing even Italy Spain the all these
countries they get people over from
North Africa all day they come in they
have no respect for the culture of
Europe no respect for the history of
Europe they come in they rape all the
women like it's their job they do all
these awful awful things to the
communities they take over entire towns
what are we supposed to do bail them out
when it turns hot when it gets into a
real the issue is the the unchecked
immigration and these videos of people
landing on on boats and rushing into the
country yeah I don't think the issue is
immigration no not immigration as a
whole but these are people that nobody
knows who they are somebody came with a
goat yesterday on an NGO boat into Italy
there was a video of well could have
been an emotional support it's an asylum
Seeker what are you talking about it's
an asylum Seeker with his it's not an
asylum partner or whatever you want to
call it goat is not seeking Asylum
that's true no the goat well the goat
might be because God knows what's
happening to him on that boat but goats
goats are based and we like goats and
the issue is this is where I want to be
careful of not conf ating if there's a
legitimate Asylum case and the issue is
no no no no no no no no no no no they're
not asy they're not asy them they're not
the these people are economic migrants
as per the UN yes so when people are
like like I think it's important to tr
the distinction specifically because
it's the argument used by the left to
justify having no border security so so
AOC specifically saying they're legal
asy no no no the people that we're upset
about are quite literally the people who
are criminals not the immigrants and the
Asylum Seekers who are either
legitimately coming here because they
love this country or they they want to
seek opportunity and they're find the
paperwork the people that are the issue
are the people who are breaking the laws
coming here and then continue cartel
members etc etc and then they're going
and committing crimes right right and
it's an insult to people who do it the
right way and the left is trying to make
sure that when we talk about it it's one
group yes instead of completely separate
groups of people right if people really
liked as for as for Europe you know the
problem is they're not having kids none
yeah there's a I don't know if this is
true people are saying that Italy hasn't
recorded a birth in a few months like
this I don't think that's true what did
they say Italy hasn't recorded a birth
period in three months oh please I don't
know if that's true no that's definitely
not true I no but there's but when you
look at the uh fertility rates I talked
about this last week in the US and
Europe they are collapsing right and and
it's it's it's it's not just like oh
look they're down because we've no they
were down before it's worse now yeah
it's worse but I will say the path
towards uh winning the culture war is
actually really simple at this point too
it's just anybody who wants to win just
needs to have five kids yeah it's a
long-term investment in the future this
is true yeah but I don't think that
people I mean I think about this all the
time which is like we say you should
have children but that that Tide's going
to turn really slowly and I wish that
there were more ways to get people
engaged in in making a difference right
now easy to say have children but you
can't get a house in this country right
now the interest rates are 8 who can
afford a I mean how many children see
when I come to your food bank in your
ly they can't be they can't afford kids
right now I mean if they want them to
have kids they should put some
incentives in place look at Hungary
Hungary did a great job you have four
kids you don't pay income tax yeah right
right where's that policy that child uh
tax credit I think Biden Biden was
talking about doing that Democrats were
talking about doing it I think that's a
good thing yeah it's a bipartisan issue
because if our birth rate declines too
far for too long I mean we did see an
increase in the years after coid very
very slightly not enough enough to you
know really say the tide has turned but
it should be a bipartisan crosscultural
everyone needs to be having more
children and instead The Narrative is
especially on the left well we can't
have children everyone agrees it's too
expensive but they also argue the
environment the environment can't take
this you're overpopulating there's too
much pollution this that other it's not
true you it'll be difficult to fight
that narrative and ultimately as much as
I would love it if just conservatives
had millions of children to eat
ultimately you need a lot of people
including the moderates who are on the
fence who might hear these AR
the problem is is it's very very much
perception and standards and people
don't want to live beneath the modern
standards and that's that I look I I get
it I can respect it but I don't know how
you can look at people who came to this
country on boats and landed on on
desolate Shores with their kids these
people were like imagine if imagine if
the the original Pioneers who came to
this country were like n I can't have a
family cuz I can't afford Med medical
care a house uh the you know uh insert
insert insert yeah no 20% of the people
died on the boats and they came here
anyway with nothing and now I know I
know people are saying yeah but like you
can't even build house back then you
could like build a fortress or like you
could you or you could build a little
house somewhere in the middle of the
Woods at least and people would work
with you to build houses and it's like
you could move out of cities and
struggle and have a 20% chance of death
like the original pioneers and colonists
and then find a look if you move out of
the city and go somewhere where it's
rural where the houses are really cheap
and then you start doing the work the
physical labor to build your house you
have a 100% survival chance but are
people built like that anymore that's
the issue I don't think anybody but but
saying saying that we're not built like
that is not an excuse as to why the
people who came before us were Hardy and
more tough more resilient and more more
willing to take the risks just saying
like it's too hard today I'll be like it
was harder back then I don't certainly
you can succeed I don't believe that
that there's a that money is the real
deciding factor like people's inability
to afford to have kids I like I don't
think that that's the real deciding
factor um I don't know I don't know that
I have a strong opinion on what it is um
I think it's probably cultural and has
to do with with their with people's
upbringing and stuff but you know there
have been a lot of times where or
there's a long time of our history where
people had a significantly lower
standard of living and they were
punching out kids like it was their job
it's not that it's not that you know
they have to have X amount of dollars to
be able to afford kids when you have
kids no matter how much money you make
unless you're like really independently
wealthy you probably always feel like if
you had a little more it would be easier
you know and so really the thing is if
you want to have kids you go and have
kids that's what people do if people
find it important to have kids they
don't wait until they have certain
amount of money they want to have kids
they have kids yeah America's declining
birth rate paral declining Community
participation so it is generally a
turning away from the building of any
sort of uh social group right I mean the
family is not just a social group but it
is a core unit of your community and you
kind of make decisions from there and I
think especially people look to one
another and so even if we can never put
a finger on exactly why people choose
not to the more people who choose not to
more likely the people around them also
opt not to have children there's a lot
of propaganda again look at that uh
what's that beast's name um H Handler
Chelsea Handler always posting those Tik
toks I didn't have any kids I flew to
France this week I'm so happy no she is
happy good for her I'm sure so I was
looking at uh 3,000 ft of land for the p
in West in a city in Marburg for
$119,000 wow not a lot of people have a
lot of people probably don't have
$199,000 you can get a loan for it to if
you want to pay pay for it but you can
get an acre of land for half that if you
got to the middle of nowhere now here's
the question if you went and bought an
acre out you know 2 hours West of DC in
the middle of a field somewhere bought
the land built a a a makeshift little
Hut for your family your family was
filthy covered in dirt bathing in the
swimming hole and you were eating and
hunting for food and then you were
slowly cutting down cutting down trees
and having your kids help you build your
house which was very small would anyone
consider that to be a reasonable
standard of living for people in this
country CPS would be there instaneous
answer no no I don't think CPS would be
there instantaneously not at all because
there's tons of of of families that are
completely neglected and ignored and
these children are left to suffer I'm
talking about parents who actually
taking care of their kids the
oldfashioned way they'd probably be
completely ignored but nobody wants to
do that right the idea that you would be
living in the wilderness basically with
no resource no electricity living off
the land is Unthinkable and unheard of
and that is the difference between then
and now back then granted you didn't
really buy the land you just went and
set up somewhere where no one had a
claim
now you Havey it you'll M meaning you
got you got have some savs but nobody's
going to do it nobody nobody thinks it's
reasonable to buy an acre of land and
then start building a house you know
taking care of their family or even more
reasonably you could buy probably five
acres for $10,000 somewhere far out in
the middle are there jobs out there
that's the thing do you need a job I'm
talking about eating deer and eating
eating wild fruit and learning which
leaves you can eat so our ancestors
quite literally did this knowing like
hey witer might come we might die but
they're like we're going to hunt we're
going to we're going and they had basic
skills but people today don't have this
and so again I think it is unreasonable
to expect anyone to do this but this is
creates the predicament when we say we
can't afford a house we're saying we
can't afford insulation air conditioning
clean running water all of these things
are part of the standard that we have to
maintain and we expect to maintain for
our families but no one's going to have
no one wants to have kids unless they
can maintain what is effectively living
like a space King by medieval standards
the idea that your house is insulated or
that you have running water is like the
Kings didn't even have this granted
Roman Empire had Endor Plumbing my point
is as the uh we've talked about how
technology becomes necessity luxury
becomes necessity when cell phones come
out only rich people the wealthiest
people have them and you don't need to
have a cell phone but if you do wow now
cell phones are you have to have it
right you can't get a job without it and
these things cost money so now all of
these luxuries have become necessi and
no one can AFF to do it and nobody wants
to go and live back off the dirt like we
used to back in the day no I think it
would be impossible for people to over I
mean the people I know who do really
live off the grid uh very few of them
have a lot of children and I think that
there are a lot of reasons for that
right it it is the reason we have iPad
kids is because modern conveniences are
built into a lot of parenting nowadays
and it's not that it's bad or good
although it's not great and usually both
parents are out of the household now the
mother's not there with the kids anymore
right and to maintain a modern standard
of living you would need both incomes in
mostes you you need it it's it's I mean
people are not getting by well it's it's
really and and another part of this is
the no fault divorces yeah that ruin the
men they have to be careful and then the
child support comes in and then you get
ruined and everything you built you get
screwed there's there's very the
society's not set up to incentivize it
there is not a lot of incentive for
people to get married anymore in the
United States there's there's very very
little incentive um if you have if you
the other way around there's a
tremendous disincentive yeah yes fair
enough um if you which is funny because
like statistically it Bears out that
children who are born to married
families do better right there's all
sorts of benefits keeping the there's no
cultural incentive but actually if you
look at it marriage is hugely beneficial
and so we have to remind people why we
had marriage in the first plate that
there was a good thing there's Mar
marriage is beneficial to to individuals
to families to people but all of the
outside incentives disincentivize
marriage all of the things that that our
society does the media disincentivizes
it all of the I mean social media yeah
absolutely so and and until we can
remedy that I think that we're going to
continue to have you know instability in
in family
creation and in culture I mean again
family is at the core of all Society so
if the family isn't stable why would the
society be stable that doesn't make
sense mhm yep it's very true I think at
a certain point you know someone super
chated talking about Japan for instance
population's going to dramatically
decline it's going to have very
interesting effects on global power
structures and then there will be a
pendulum swinging the other direction I
think you can say that as well if you
look at Japan they currently have all
the younger people in the like in our
generation pardon me are all essentially
making all their money from taking care
of the elderly like it's like the whole
industry in Japan and it's not
longm yeah they're not having kids
they're too busy with their jobs etc etc
it's it's a whole cultural problem
feminism when when uh when we eliminated
the female traditional role and had
women uh take on the male traditional
role right this is what ends up
happening very true this is the Ann what
are we like 50 years into feminism a
little more what do you say we are it's
not it's not feminism it's the birth
control
pill I I think it's one of the same
that's the component of it with no
because you can you can have you can
have feminism and have have the ideas
all you want but if you don't have the
birth control pill and people people
just do not have the capacity to behave
the way that they do now the free sex
the free love stuff that doesn't happen
that doesn't happen no well big time
that's abortion maybe but I think I
think that you wouldn't get to the point
where abortion happens regularly if you
didn't have the pill the pill allows
women to go to work regularly the pill
allows a lot of women it it stabiliz wom
go to work if they were on the if they
weren't on the pill they'll end up
getting pregnant have take care of it
just allows people to act like FAL
animals exactly pill had a huge I I I
agree and so does abortion but there are
a lot of women who don't take birth
control pills who go to work it is it is
a social Norm that women must work
that's it women must get jobs and must
take care of themselves I but that that
is a that is a an effect of the pill
that is not that is not C A Cause I I
don't I don't think so I don't think you
can say that they're related in that way
they're they're they're they're two
things that are component of a similar
thing but they're independent of each
other yeah I also think that there
during the birth control movement you
know there were already women who were
working who thought well now that I'm
liberated I have my own money I want to
be able to behave different sexually I
mean I want a different life I think in
some ways women entering to the
workforce encourage them to get on birth
control but I don't think it's the other
way around there were all kinds of
reasons that women wanted or S thought
that you know the women's Li movement
was a attractive and ultimately like I
said with AI they pay a price that they
don't know what it will be and the birth
control pill is incredibly dangerous
it's overprescribed in my opinion it
does I think you're right it does allow
women to stay in the workforce for
longer but I think they were already
looking for ways out I think there were
arguments against separating the family
before the birth control the first step
that allowed women to behave as men I
don't think that's true SE I think that
women already were there were there were
women's movements to give them I mean
this was the whole argument suffrage
right men can vote so we should be able
to do that that has nothing to do with
the birth control pill there's this been
going on for a long time is it good and
I think probably birth control expedited
it I'm no fan of birth control pill but
I don't think that it was the birth
control pill that opened the door for
feminism it was already there it was
just a ticking Time Bomb I think in some
ways feminism allowed people to be more
accepting of birth control pill because
they saw it as this Progressive choice
for women I I I agree with an Clair on
that the I looked it up the birth birth
control was invented in 1950 was when it
was first introduced but like women's
suffrage movement and women entering the
workplace was happening in the early
1900s these these Arguments for changing
in the in the in the roles happen with
industrialization and probably
population expansion and the security
State when women became secure they no
longer they they no longer need men in
the same way that men need women so you
know if you go back to well before
industrialization women are more
vulnerable than men men protect women
but once we eliminated the Bears the
Wolves the coyotes and the external
threats and had centralized police
forces now it's like the state can
function as the man for the women in
general and the women can go do whatever
they want but now they need money to do
whatever they want right which probably
leads to the creation of birth control
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at Tim cast.com
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out out and
we'll see you all next
time